come and see what everyone's talking
about a comb which means peace be unto
you welcome to another episode of the
Dene show we'd like to thank everybody
who's been viewing us every week we're
excited to get a lot of your emails we
try to encourage people to send us your
comments and suggestions some of the
questions that are more scholarly
questions the fit questions we ask that
you don't send us those because I'm not
a scholar and some of the questions that
we encourage are from non-muslims people
wanting to know about Islam
what does Islam mean who are the Muslims
what is this Quran who is this Messenger
Muhammad so to be open mind and humble
hearted and send your questions and
that's what we're going to be discussing
on this episode of the Deen show a
question that someone wrote in and then
we're going to discuss this question
turn it into a topic and from there
let's you be the judge see if you can
benefit from this now I'm going to go
ahead and bring out my next guest and
we'll hit the question and then let's
you benefit when we come back on the
Deen show
muhammad is his messenger Allah
[Music]
there's only one but Jesus was his
messenger no I did that maybe it maybe
it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum I think oh so now I know
how to go through how are you very good
I'm gonna alright so for those of you
that have never seen the Deen show
somebody kind of twisted John you're
sitting next to a Muslim he said come
watch this show
I just wish peace upon him he wished it
back upon me and now we're just here
talking about good stuff peace things
that can bring you peace is Islam so
we're gonna be talking about this
question that we got in from a non
Muslim and this is something that I'm
sure a lot of people are out there
probably possibly thinking the same
thing now remember we want you to be
sincere with yourself as you're
listening to this and advice that will
give towards the end them the person
says I don't like to be religious
because it makes me depressed
I would not be able to live your life is
boring saying that you know living Islam
is boring what do you do for fun
everything is forbidden in Islam can't
date oh you can't meet your soulmate you
see there's a lot of for Muslim watching
said man this person is already there
probably the Muslims probably laughing
this is you know but it's a big
misconception that people have and we're
seeing that right here come on you can't
go clubbing god forbid if you missed
that Friday Saturday night at the club
you know you got to get that VIP card
god forbid if I can't do that okay you
can't have a occasional drink oh you
know kool-aid and orange juice and all
the other hundreds of drink that are out
there that's not enough but we got to
have that jack on the rocks ah okay
you can't have sex if you feel like it I
just want to get down so the person
saying I want to get down and I want to
do it that's the boring life Eddie
women in your religion cover from head
to toe there's no freedom at all I had
my own words into this a little bit it's
probably the sisters who are Muslim
which we know that many more women are
coming to us are probably laughing at
this but the person has you know given
this question I'm just adding a little
humor to this book because it's funny to
us but we hope you're still listening
look but men can have more wives as long
as I know this is ridiculous man it's
the best not to follow any religion I
feel sorry for the Muslim females and
etc etc they can have more wives and
they put the the woman down and the
other final thing is the media and look
at you know the terrorism with media and
associating Islam and all these things
blowing up like I said I really love my
life and the things I'm enjoying in it
right now after we all die we go to
heaven anyway thank you very much by the
way for sending this forgive me if I was
a little sarcastic because it's funny
because we're gonna explain and
hopefully clear your mind from all the
junk that it's not your fault if you're
going on if you're sincere and you want
to know the truth after you get the
truth delivered to you now you're going
to be responsible in front of the in
front of your Creator so we're going to
talk about this I hope I translated this
or read it right you can understand what
she's talking about
okay let's go ahead and talk about this
there's a lot of points here a lot of
misconceptions but it's something that
the average person is thinking I think
the first comment we have to talk about
is that are the life of a Muslim a
submissive Muslim is boring boring is
the fundamental problem in this email
isn't one of not being convinced of
Islam yeah
the fundamental problem is that this
person is looking at Islam from the
point of view of how is it going to
serve me hmm the very fundamental
question in Islam is how do I serve God
yes and once you come into that
submission you are showered with all
sorts of benefits and favors that you
couldn't have even imagined the ultimate
one of which is peace with yourself
peace now
still one of the great scholars of Assam
I mean Tamera Mahalo he talked about the
two fundamental obstacles that come in
the way of people that want to reach the
truth and he said in Arabic that the
words are shabu hat and shahe wat doubts
yeah and desires desires doubts and
desires some people they're not sure if
this is the truth if they became sure
they would follow it yeah other people
even if they were made sure it's true
that still wouldn't be enough for them
to follow it because they are too
addicted to their own desires and I
clubs drinking all these other this
laundry list of items yeah these desires
the thing of it is in order to truly
have to be committed to the truth it's
not enough that we share the ideas of
what is true and what isn't even though
at the end of your email you talked
about you know women having to cover and
men getting to have four you know four
wives and things like that which is
actually a minor issue your major issue
even in your mind that will you organize
your thoughts in your email your major
problem is having to give up what you
love that's your major problem then this
other stuff really it's secondary we
could talk about it too but really we
have to try and deal with the major
issue and the major issue is one's own
desires one's own inclinations now the
thing of it is religion in our times is
almost look like a casual lifestyle kind
of fashionable kind of thing yeah I'm
into this right now and I'll try that
out too and I'll try that out too it's
kind of like you know changing fashions
statements yes you know yeah or
different music genres I was in the
country now into hip-hop or something
you know it's like a fashionable
something convenient that you just
exactly is very casual yeah it's very
casual and the idea behind it is I'm
going to do it basically to find some
entertainment for myself right it's
gonna be something curious for me that's
so you might see a lot of these
different places they got the rock bands
and you know just try and write I'll
draw the people in any which way
exactly so a lot of religions because
they're losing their followers what
they're adding is an element of
entertainment into the religion so that
people will stick around right yeah so
now the
first fundamental question we have or
concerns we have for such a person is
you haven't sorted out why you were put
on this earth so is the reality of the
human being that he was here - he or she
was here - just eat drink sleep have sex
have fun and die was that is that the
purpose of their life and if it is the
purpose of you if that is the purpose of
your life and there is nothing coming I
mean you're saying there's a heaven
afterwards so everybody goes to heaven
no matter what they do no matter how
many people they murdered no matter how
many kinds of crimes did it what kind of
God would it be that would let just any
any of these people get away with their
crimes
with all of this injustice doesn't
happened on the earth and if you're
saying if you would think a little
deeply about this and say no people that
do great horrible crimes and justices
have to be punished even your own
limited intellect tells you this much
then understand if you say well the
stuff that I'm doing is not so bad it's
not so bad when the guy kills somebody
you know what he says to himself that's
not so bad there's much worse that can
be done yeah right we were talking about
relativity of ethics so the person who's
messed up says there's people far worse
than I am so I shouldn't be worried
because there's people you know if a guy
kills one he says at least I didn't kill
100 yeah right
so this mentality of saying well what
what I'm doing is just enjoying myself
I'm not you know there's no consequences
of this is because you've decided to
you've become the judge of what is right
and what's wrong what Muslims are
arguing with all sincerity and humility
is that you and I are not in a position
in the absolute sense to decide even
what is good or harmful for our own
selves even what's good and harmful for
our own selves we were not in a position
to know what is coming ahead of us
nobody left this earth went into the
ground got buried and came back and told
us there's a light at the end of the
tunnel and there's a heaven and there's
a hell nobody came back and told us you
can't say that you know this on your own
from human experience this is knowledge
beyond yourself so when you say with
full confidence after this half the
email about turning this life into
heaven for yourself doing whatever you
want that's heaven isn't it yeah so
turning this life into a
life of pleasure for yourself and then
you argue well I'm going to party here
and then when I die there's more coming
there's more coming then you've decided
to make a pass judgment on something you
have no knowledge of you have no
knowledge of this you know
Allah is Arjun speaks he says that the
whole Allah and Allah he Malik on the
moon are you saying on behalf of God
what you have no knowledge of are you
saying on behalf of Allah which you have
no idea about so the idea that you're
okay in the hereafter is almost like a
delusion and actually in fact it is a
delusion that I'm doing alright there's
nothing wrong there's nothing wrong with
my life and especially you know if
you're a young person and you think your
whole life is ahead of you how many
young people that thought their whole
life was ahead of them that we're going
to party away their life died in a car
accident that died on the way to the
club that never got a chance to live out
their entire life that the way they had
planned and so their false hopes
your false aspirations you think these
things are going to bring you happiness
you know what you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction you're never satisfied
you're never going to be fulfilled
you're never going to be content what we
are offering in Islam what we have found
in Islam for ourselves is a means by
which our hearts are at peace they're at
rest they're not discontent we are
pleased with what we have and I promise
you you know and one of the most
beautiful things in Islam is finding
your soulmate that is one of the most
beautiful gift since I'm you but you're
always one of the things right that's
what I mean your soulmate you can't meet
your soulmate you see what is a soulmate
it's not just about physical desires
physical pleasures I'm sure you and
other people you know I've had the
experience of thinking they found their
soulmate getting used getting abused
getting manipulated like a you know like
a toy and then being thrown off being
you know disregarded and people like
that you know when somebody uses you
like that and somebody takes advantage
of you like that you lose respect for
yourself and you lose respect for others
so the next time around you're gonna do
it to someone else and you're not going
to feel so bad about it either because
you've lost a little bit of your
humanity every single time what Islam is
is so powerful we treat our women with
the utmost respect our messenger told us
allah llahu salaam the best of you are
the ones who are best of their spouses
and i'm the best of mine you know so he
teaches us to be the most merciful kind
and lenient towards our spouses and
really I don't want to talk about the
reality of spousal abuse in the world
which happens in the Muslim world and it
happens in the non-muslim world
I'm not saying Muslims are not guilty of
spousal abuse they are that's the defect
in that individual yes this is not to
speak anything of Islam and actually
they violated some very basic principles
of Islam if they're engaged in abusing
their spouse this is one of the most
prized you know responsibilities one of
the highest responsibilities a man has
in this life as a Muslim is taking care
of his wife this is one of the things
he's going to be interrogated about in
front of Allah how did you deal with her
were you kind to her did you take care
of her did you protect her did you honor
her did you teach her etc etcetera these
are the things that you know Muslim men
are supposed to take very very seriously
but the bottom line isn't even this
issue the bottom line is forget men this
religion is not about men versus women
that's not the issue the issue is you
and your Lord you and your provider he
gave you all of these things to enjoy
and he's asking you you can be deluded
by these things you could be you know
dissuaded by these things or you can
have eternal pleasure
eternal life something a pleasure far
beyond what what these few things that
you're obsessed with can ever help you
in you know you're gonna get drunk and
you're gonna throw up and you're gonna
have a hangover you're gonna go to the
club you're gonna wake up somewhere you
don't even know what happened to you the
night before you're going to do these
things thinking it's going to bring you
pleasure and it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain you think you're happy you're
kidding yourself you really are so that
those two next you recover the soulmate
and many things before that and the
clubbing you know come on club you know
the clubbing and the occasional drink so
is this really where the happiness is
you know going from club Friday to
Friday so I live and work you know
throughout the week to make enough money
to enjoy my Friday or my Saturday sure
and then I get to talk about it Monday
with all the friends and then we look
forward to doing it again next Friday so
it goes from Friday to front your whole
life is just a week your whole life is
just a
piete cycle of that entire week that's
all it is that's all your purpose
amounts to and really I say why do
people love alcohol so much yeah there's
my personal take on it it may or may not
be true it's an escape from reality why
do people get into drugs yeah it's an
escape from reality your life is so bad
you got so many problems you got nothing
to look forward to in your life the only
thing you have to look forward to is
that time where you will jump around
like a wild animal drink something to
lose touch with your problems your
reality your own purpose right so from
weekend a weekend you're just looking to
get high or you know get away from this
world this the reality around you you
don't want to take responsibility for
why you were put on this earth that's
what it is you're trying to run away
from it you're trying to escape it you
know even if you're trying to find
pleasure if you're trying to find you
know physical pleasure if you're trying
to find monetary benefit you know people
who run after money their entire life
they're still not happy they still don't
find happiness they'll buy this big old
mansion that they thought they would
love and after a couple of months of
living in that mansion they'll find
somebody else's mentioned that's nicer
and say man I don't have that and
there's a void in their heart it's never
going to be fulfilled your greed your
lust it's never going to be fulfilled
faith real faith true faith offer
something that nothing else can offer it
can fill your heart with contentment
that's what we're offering so you have
to fight your desires you have to for a
moment maybe for a day for a week we ask
you just to put your desires aside just
put them aside for a little while and
just deeply reflect on the truth reflect
on your real purpose in life and see if
that can push you in a different
direction there were people like much
like you now we're in a life of really
entertaining themselves drowning
themselves in in all of their seductions
and Allah gifted them with just a
responsibility or just a few moments of
taking a seat back pulling themselves
out of that cycle and thinking about it
for a moment and they found the truth
and they are now they are at more peace
now than they were ever before why is it
do you think that a young man a young
Muslim man a young Muslim woman you know
good-looking healthy smart you know
making good money etc etc is not going
to go to the club it has all the power
to know what's stopping him
is so powerful that it's it's not
tempting him like attempts you why is it
that he's able to fight that he's got
something so powerful that nobody else
can see and we want to share that
treasure with you wanna sure that's
that's what we want you to experience
you know a lot of us we some of us are
just coming over from what we call
jaliyah coming over from the days of
ignorance some people you know they can
relate to this and they're laughing at
it now because they have that true peace
and that contentment they don't have to
go to the club they don't have to go
chasing the material world but why do
you think it is that someone you know
we've seen this you know the woman she
because the next point she mentions is
you know women your religion they got a
cover from head to toe but you'll see
women just fighting so hard is like
freezing outside and she's got you know
the the skirt coming up and you're like
man ain't you cold she's just fighting
but now the cold weather will still have
to have her put on some kind of some
clothes
yeah or she'll have to give out you know
the number the guys are out there you
know what their agenda is they want to
satisfy their desires the woman she
feels insecure she's not giving at least
if her phone's not blowing up and 20
guys are calling her a date she's got to
have this this feeding to her ego and it
becomes like a game it becomes like you
know this life we're just playing with
each other
and it's really what a lot of times our
sisters don't realize in humanity is
that they're actually being used they
think they're addressing how they want
you don't want that you just want your
just appealing to the desires of men
that's what they want it's not what you
want they wanted more than you do they
want you to address half-naked you know
and so the the thing about hijab and
covering and modesty and things like
that first and foremost it's a
commandment in Islam well are the Muslim
woman covers she she covers herself in a
certain way why because she is convinced
this is a commandment a prescription
from her Lord and what her Lord says is
better for her and her fulfilling her
purpose
that's the s the essential point of this
issue but just to speak about clothing a
little bit you know there are in Islam
we say that there are three purposes of
clothing there are three purposes of
clothing one purpose of clothing is
protecting yourself
the elements of the weather like you
just mentioned another purpose of
clothing is beautification another
purpose of clothing is modesty there are
three purposes protection beautification
and modesty but the priority is
different in Islam the priority first is
what modesty that's the first priority
you have to have decency you have to
have you know you shouldn't be
objectified
you know so that's the first purpose the
second purpose in of clothing in Islam
of course is protection from the weather
and and together with beautification
there's nothing wrong with wearing nice
nice clothes so long as you are guarding
your modesty right what happens in a lot
of non-muslim culture is that a lot of
times people don't care about modesty at
all they don't even care sometimes about
protecting themselves from the weather
like you said yeah what are they
concerned about what they think is
beautification yeah that's what their
concerns got she don't want the whistle
but she's got to have it yeah so so this
is the you know it's it's a change of
shift because you know and we say
modesty which is a kindness it's an
aspect of humility and why does it
Muslim have to have humility because
they've acknowledged that they're not in
charge of their life there's a higher
power yeah so even in their their speech
even in their daily life in how they
spend their time and their clothing
clothing is just one manifestation of
humility but we argue that humility has
to be something that's a part of your
speech your demeanor your mannerisms the
way you speak to people the way you deal
with your family the way you deal with
your Lord there has to be humility all
around and one of those aspects is
humility in clothing yeah that's
interesting we're almost out of time
just a few more points we will hope that
you will continue on because this
program is very short and we just want
to give you a good taste and clear some
of the junk that's out there that the
the point about these the woman it seems
like the Muslim women who do cover-up
they make a conscious decision even
people that might come from abroad they
come over here yeah this is the
opportunity to take off the head job
they wear it they still there they're
there they're not slaves to their desire
their slaves to their Creator certain
they feel a great commitment to do this
and you have many Americans women who
are taking a conscious decision and
putting this on their own now for
do this amazing thing now the other
point that the person brought up is
about the organized religion you hear
this a lot where person will be like you
know that all religions are just
man-made and we I would agree we
shouldn't have to follow a man-made
religion organized by men so how did we
clear up this miss concern I think
what's happened is at least in Western
society there's been a lot of
disappointment with certain religions
because you could see clearly the
logical contradictions in them like
right off the bat you don't have to go
deep into finding the logical
contradictions you could see them right
off the bat so what's happened is that
stigma has been we've taken that that
paint and we brushed all the religions
with the same paint and we've said
basically oh this one's met religion one
is man-made religion two is man-made
therefore all the others must be
man-made too so we actually stopped
looking into religion altogether right
what we're arguing is that's not a fair
assessment you know just like you don't
judge you know you don't need two people
from a certain race and then pass
judgment on the entire race you don't
need two people of that gender and then
pass judgment of the entire gender same
same thing with religion you come across
a certain religion and you're not
satisfied with it you didn't find it
convincing that's not fair for you to
just brush off all other religions and
say oh they're all man-made that's
actually an oversimplification and a an
intellectual laziness on your part
you're actually just justifying to
yourself that yeah I was kind of
thinking about submitting to my creator
I didn't find something you know
satisfying yeah so I'm just gonna go
back to my old distractions right it's
kind of like I'll tell you you you're
only gonna dig you know the analogy
you're only gonna dig into something and
you're going to only spend effort and
time in something that you think is
worth it like if I ask you to dig a hole
into the ground for five dollars and dig
ten feet half the day you won't do it
but if I say dig ten feet and I'll give
you twenty thousand you'll start
shoveling yeah so you only put time and
effort into something that you think is
worth it if you think the truth and
finding the purpose in your life is
worth it you'll dig and not find then
dig again and not find and dig again and
not find until you find right you're
gonna keep on digging but this this
attitude of Oh generally just
not even any inquiry without even caring
to look at the matter you just say oh
you know I don't have to look into it I
already know that there's nothing that's
all man-made we're all gonna go to
heaven well the idea of heaven comes
from religion anyway so where did you
get that idea right you're jumping the
gun and you're it's actually showing
your intellectual laziness your
emotional laziness and perhaps the
reason is maybe you don't want to find
the truth
maybe it's deep inside you you're scared
that if you find the truth it's gonna
ask you to change yourself and if you
don't want to change yourself unless
this is no Quran well you rebuild
insanity of Jorah imama
yes oh yeah I don't work the AMA very
beautiful he says no the human being he
wants to continue to disobey and explode
in his disobedience that is in front of
him right away he wants to stay in that
rut yeah and then that's what leads him
to a score when is the Judgment Day
coming anyway when his resurrection
coming it's not gonna happen well I'm
gonna go to heaven look at what Allah
said and look at what you're saying it's
like he drew a picture of what you're
saying Subhan Allah you know what when I
study you Quran and then I look at the
kinds of questions people ask it's
incredible Allah knows us better than we
know ourselves you're not the first
person to ask this question there have
been hundreds of thousands of people
before millions if not that have asked
the same question of their Lord of their
purpose in life and there are people who
found that answer and we're sincere to
themselves
and there were people who passed by
these responses and said no my desires
my temptations my seductions are just
too powerful for me I'm gonna stay in
this mess you have to decide if you're
stronger than your desires and I want to
create an urgency with this person I
know there's sincere in the many
thousands that are watching that death
is a reality it's not something that
this should be put off searching for the
truth thousands of people just in
America die every day
I'm told that close to 150 thousand died
globally so death can reach us at any
time and that's the fact and we should
kind of get on the ball about finding
what the true purpose of our life is
absolutely you know I never continued
Rick UL mode well no continuity Moshe
ADA Allah says wherever you may be death
will come to you even if you are in
fortified camps you're in the best
security system death does not need to
knock on your door
we'll come right to you you could be in
your beds you could be in your sleep you
could be driving to work you could be
perfectly healthy one day and a heart
attack and died the next we say it was
sudden called sudden death
right cause of death unknown this
happens to death is not in your hands it
is the hands of your Creator and because
there's no timeline you think you make a
forty year plan you may not even have
three hours left on this earth I don't
know how much time I have left you don't
know how much time you have left so you
we have to have a sense of urgency to
finding our purpose because once that
taught that the clock stops ticking and
we leave this earth then like one of the
Companions of the Prophet said I leave
only Allahu Allah know he said people
are sleeping
it's beautiful he said people are
sleeping and when they die is when they
wake up that's when their eyes opened
and now soon the young people are asleep
so we ask that you wake up before you go
into the grave where everybody else
thinks you've been put to sleep the
reality will be you've actually been
woken up at that point and you don't we
don't want we don't wish that upon you
we don't wish that you wake up at that
point we wish upon you that you wake up
now that you look at and think about
your purpose and reality now and it's
not fair now that you expect the Creator
or you go to your boss and he told you
and he gave you a list of
responsibilities you neglected it now
you want to get paid at the end yeah
exactly does it make sense okay thank
you for being with us light welcome we
hope to have you back again in sha Allah
Allah thank you I really hope that
you're sincere that you're honest and I
sure that you and I'm sure that you want
to know the truth and I hope that this
somewhat will stimulate you to continue
on in your journey do the most important
thing ask the one who created this
universe and everything in it take the
first step don't fight the guidance ask
him to guide you the one who created you
and took care of you and is still taking
care of you ask him for the guidance and
he created you I mean one of the
beautiful thing is that he's the most
loving and the most merciful and be
unfair that he wouldn't guide you but
it's unfair to yourself you don't even
ask him to give you the guidance so ask
him to guide you take that first step
that first crucial step to wanting to
know the truth and then when the truth
comes beyond it is very simple and Islam
is calling you to something that's in
your very nature to be a slave to be
one who surrenders and submits to just
God alone and not his creation and if
you can dig this this simple thing then
everything else will fall in place it's
a very beautiful way of life and we hope
that you got to benefit from this show
and we look forward to having you again
God willing insha'Allah on the Deen show
until next time i Salam alaikum peace be
unto you
let's see what everyone's talking about
who you find one contradiction it can't
be from God but the rational idea the
rational explanation is you do your best
to give up for spring guy that's why I
wouldn't never give up spreading this
message okay you take that necessary
step you don't know if you're gonna live
till tomorrow so you got to find that
urgency to do the right thing right now
the reality of life usually doesn't sink
in until tragedy commas you get a few
bad people the media grabs a hold of
that and spends it the way they want to
if you say that you're not believe in
Jesus you have stepped outside of this
man you cannot be a Muslim is that ended
our faith to be both kickback relaxes
your chill up with the Deen show God's
will it you're living it every day at
night so listen let me tell you a bit
about a boy your flight
it's lame the true religion has every
proper teachers I don't know what
Abraham Moses even Jesus called to
worship the one true God and that's the
base of the slab let me let her get
along brothers
all around the blow coming to drop a bit
of knowledge from the comfort of your
home so ladies and gents brothers and
sisters get ready you're watching the
teen show take it away
Eddie